someone told me a certain different
years you said that you got your DNA
tested Rosalee now is it true you did
this
okay there's if there's a thing called
23andme yeah yeah we're it's a D that
you spit in a cup and you mail it to
some nerds and then they look at it they
put it in a anything called the center
site centrifuge cyclotron or cyclotron
and they look at it under a microscope
and they send you back a map that shows
you where all of your DNA came from sure
so I did it and they sent me my man sure
enough my the map of the world and and
of course I hit all the pasty countries
had my DNA like Sweden in Germany in
England all the Ireland pasty pasty
right right then there I had a huge
spike in Mongolia you did a big chunk of
my DNA comes from Mongolia so I'm sort
of going but they have an 800 m you can
call them and so I call him up and go
hey I got my map and it's really
interesting I got all the pasty white
countries and what's with Mongolia
what's going on on my map and the person
on the phone didn't even pause just said
yeah that's Genghis Khan it's like what
it's like yeah Genghis Khan had sex with
everything
most people are descended from Genghis
Khan Wow there are trees that are
descendants of Genghis Khan he would and
that must have been some superior semen
inside a Genghis Khan's balls because
that guy he was in just think about this
for a second that's like tight leather
pants right that don't breathe right you
know any rock star will tell you yeah
and then he's on a saddle all day ten
hours of a saddle just crushing this
guy's nuts and he's riding to BAM boom
BAM and then he gets off at a village he
goes hey guys I'm conquering your
village I'm Ganga slip before we go any
further I'm just gonna have sex with
everybody that's what I do I just
and his semen was like ready to go no
problem eight hours in the saddle if I
send a text near my scrotum my bloodline
is you know you should have added that
emoji that's was innocent way too much
radiation then I got to go to bed for 19
you